avec armelle charrier bonjour armelle
bonjour pauline sandrine en parlait à
l'instant et on viens de l'entendre joe
biden a annoncé hier une nouvelle aide
militaire de 800 millions de dollars
pour l'ukraine alors de quoi s'agit-il
exactement
alors il a on a un peu des détails sur
ce que va comprendre la enveloppe de 800
millions sachant que du coup vont être
libérés des obusiers chat majorité ça
aide évidemment les ukrainiens dans
cette guerre avoir beaucoup de munitions
aussi des obus et puis rajouter des
drones qui ne sont pas les mêmes que
ceux qui ont déjà été livrés et donc
sont des droïdes un peu kamikaze qui se
colle et donc du coup là il va y avoir
d'autres types de typologie de drones
qui vont être fournies par les
américains
800 millions donc c'est une aide
conséquente en plus sachant que si on
additionne toutes les aides américaines
on arrive à peu près à la somme de 4
milliards aujourd'hui pour l'armement
ukrainien au même moment le fonds
monétaire international est appelé à
l'aide par l'ukraine le pays dit avoir
besoin de 7 milliards de dollars par
mois pour compenser ces pertes
économiques causées par la guerre c'est
énorme c'est énorme et c'est pour ça que
le fonds monétaire international a été
saisie pourquoi demander autant dans un
risque de guerre parce que le pays est
vraiment à l'arrêt avec des conséquences
à foix immédiate et sur le long terme
immédiate parce qu'il s'agit d'une
guerre bien évidemment et que du coup
vous avez en tête les techs truction des
maisons les destructions des vides que
l'on peut voir donc il faut rebâtir tout
simplement aussi derrière vous avez
aussi les destructions qui sont une
destruction de routes qui sont aussi des
destructions de chemin de fer c'est là
que les russes travaillent à la limite
j'allais dire avec le plus d'assiduité
pour casser justement
l'approvisionnement qui pourrait aller
vers l'armée ukrainienne mais donc du
coup après ça va manquer à la vie civile
de l'ukraine juste cette organisation là
vous avez aussi le fait que les usines
de défense ont été visés donc elles sont
à l'arrêt que vous avez le nombre
d'emplois dans les villes tout
simplement quand vous avez plus de 5
millions aujourd'hui de réfugiés à
l'extérieur mais que vous avez ça aussi
à l'intérieur vous imaginez bien que
vous avez tous le nom d'emplois et puis
vous avez aussi surtout la grande
denrées j'allais dire de l'ukraine qui
se retrouve aujourd'hui être à l'arrêt
c'est l'agriculture c'est rappelez vous
cette belle couleur jaune qu'il y a sur
le drapeau ukrainien bleu pour le ciel
et jaune pour la couleur des blés
l'agriculture qui est à l'arrêt certains
essaient de travailler dans les champs
comme ils peuvent mais quoi qu'il en
soit l'agriculture soit elle ne produit
plus soit quand elle produit aujourd'hui
eh bien les continents sont aujourd'hui
dans l'est dans les ports à odessa sont
dans les bateaux sac général écrit ce
que l'on voit ensuite en afrique la
crise du pain qui sont sur les bords de
la méditerranée
parce que l'ukraine aujourd'hui elle
ressemble un pays en guerre ça vous
explique pourquoi vous avez ce chiffre
très étonnant de 7 milliards mais qu'on
est dans un pays effectivement très
touché alors côté russe vladimir poutine
a annoncé hier une série de sanctions à
l'encontre de plusieurs occidentaux et
parmi ces personnes il ya notamment
kamala harris la vice présidence
américaine oui alors il faut bien
j'allais dire quelque part dans des
sanctions avoir un côté people là encore
kamala harris vice-présidente américaine
qui est stigmatisé
c'est une réponse la dîmière poutine au
fait qu' il ya aussi les oligarques il a
aussi ses enfants lui aussi sur les
listes des personnes qui sont interdites
il a aussi mélanger ça avec la société
civile puisqu'on a aussi mark zuckerberg
qui s occupe de facebook qui a été
pointée du doigt ainsi que nombre de
politiques américains en fonction des
déclarations qu'ils ont faites c'est
cela on va te la ligne directive on a
aussi des journalistes qui ont été
montrés du doigt sur ce qu'ils ont pu
écrire en élite au c'ur sur des journaux
et puis à côté de ça et bien il ya eu
aussi des canadiens qui s'étaient
présentés qui voulaient rejoindre la
russie pareil ils ont été interdits et
on a en tête des diplomates des pays bas
et de la belgique qui est ont été
refusées certainement qu'un début pour
l'instant la france n'a pas encore été
touché mais il faut s'attendre à ce que
à un moment donné puissent aussi avoir
des annonces de cet acabit merci
beaucoup armelle pour ce décryptage on
retrouve tout de suite 100 m